hey here are once again yeah we're back
what the hell day is it today Tuesday
yeah Tuesday yeah oh yeah okay it says
right there just goes to show my [ __ ]
brain itself right I don't know we're
just warming up for the show yeah just
doing kind of a another little brief one
today cuz I guess we did a long one
yesterday cuz we talked about dark and I
kind of got all off on that cuz I was
geeking out about it um but do another
matinee show cuz we did actually watch a
new movie on Netflix last night called
the night clerk yeah a night clerk was
pretty good
not too bad actually not a horror movie
it was more like a thriller mystery type
thing sorta
yeah drama kind of um but you know so
before we get into talking about that
I've been meaning to do like a couple of
shout outs on here and I meant to do it
like the yesterday and the day before
and I forgot even though I had them
written down right here I'm a little
page but so I'm gonna shout out I'll
shout out in the main episode to like I
usually do but I wanted to thank our
newest patron mark so hello and welcome
also while we're talking about patreon a
newer patron Sidney who just doubled
their support so thank you very much for
that also Thank You Logan for your
PayPal donation and thank you Louis for
sending us the movies we got yeah
Terminator blu-ray yeah and we got oh
what's the secret in their eyes which
I've heard is actually very good I have
not seen it yet so thank you very much
for that you guys yeah and I will be
honest I'm will be on patreon for as
long as patreon exists I heard they're
getting their ass a suit off right now
for what they were they did something
wrong they changed Terms of Service on
somebody after they did some action
against them or whatever and it if they
they're probably going to lose that
lawsuit and if it does it opens up for
soup [ __ ] thousands of other patrons
and some people have said take years but
yeah usually
this might [ __ ] this might fold
patreon they did they would kind of do
what they did was is they
they sped they started suspending
accounts all right but the counts didn't
violate Terms of Service so then they
then there's a couple of those accounts
one main ones sued and after the lawsuit
hit patreon then changed the Terms of
Service to defend themselves against the
lawsuit which made it worse ya know so
there's a couple of lawsuits going on
all I've heard all I've heard lately I
don't know if any was that but they
started making them I guess to comply
with new laws that they started making
them have to charge sales tax on
particular yeah this years that's not
the problem that's the only thing this
problem had to do with kicking people
off the platform they didn't violate the
Terms of Service and then they changes
the terms of service after lawsuits you
know to try to cover their asses
evidently they didn't like I can't
comment right so will there'll be other
things if we have to leave patreon yeah
I don't worry about that kind of [ __ ]
yeah until it happens well yeah cuz you
know you never know what's gonna happen
yes looking people can say anything
looks like we finally stopped lagging
for some reason the first couple minutes
of the show [ __ ] lags badly I have no
idea why what are you talking about it's
not lagging that's just what I know I'm
just kidding I just said we move really
slowly before banks starts he says I
started watching dark last night I found
it slow and hard to understand as well
it is hard to understand I will say that
and it's more like you said it's more a
drama than it has four elements it has
crime elements it has sci-fi elements
but it's not like an action movie or
anything like that so I mean it depends
on I mean most people I know like loved
it so it depends on what kind of thing
you like like it's not super
action-packed it's more story based you
know what I'm saying if you don't like
it so far you're not gonna like it
probably not because it just gets more
and more complex yeah it goes on and
gets harder to like if you found the
first season hard to understand then by
the time the second or third one roll
around you're gonna have no idea what's
going on can always go watch star [ __ ]
is Star Trek Enterprise in a mirror
darkly wanted to that's a good time
travel story we're just gonna it's not
quite as long because I mean I mean yeah
dark that's like it's three seasons and
they're like eight eight hour episodes
each so that's really really long so
yeah so let's talk about briefly about
this new movie on Netflix it's called
the night clerk and I guess it just came
to the platform like in early June
although I think it was actually
released in February of this year but it
is technically a 2020 Mary so this has
like some fairly famous people and it
had an enormous who was in Blade Runner
2049 and yeah Judas Allen is she is
she's adorable she's a woman um also
John Leguizamo in this Helen Hunt is in
this and it's hi Sheridan who plays the
main character now this is kind of an
interesting conceit I don't know if I've
seen anything quite like this but
basically the setup of it is is that ty
Sheridan plays this guy named Bart and
he is the night clerk at a hotel and he
suffers from Asperger's syndrome yeah so
he has like all of these you know let's
call them personality quirks so he's not
very good at like you know maintaining
conversations with people he doesn't
know like when he's not supposed to say
something you know he's very socially
awkward since [ __ ] up stuff but their
obesity was actually very funny one
thing that I liked about this because
it's really hard I guess for an actor to
play a character that has a disability
like this without making it seem like
they're making fun of them or going too
far over the top I think that I think
this performance just skirts that line I
don't I don't you don't get the sense it
he's making fun of him um it is like it
is a very sympathetic portrayal but a
lot of the comedic stuff in the film
it's not a comedy but there is like a
lot of funny like awkward like cringe
kind of funny stuff comes from his
inability to interact with others but
not in a way that it's like making fun
of him necessarily I did kind of laugh
when he was going to buy the new clothes
and like he asked that old man that was
helping him out like was he's like would
you wear these pants and I was like yeah
I'd wear em and he's like well that I
don't want this and he's like oh my god
he's like because you're old
hahaha now it's like you're everyone
thinks it but no one says it out yeah
but he says it out I thought it was an
okay performance from him it wasn't yeah
it wasn't totally believable I mean yeah
you went a little better Mia with a
little over-the-top
not talking about Dustin Hoffman and
Rain Man but it well it wasn't that bad
it was that was a great performance well
I thought that was doesn't happen
yeah I think that was I think that was a
great performance by Dustin Hoffman this
one now it's just sad quit yes it's not
that kind of movie you're talking about
Hollywood c-listers mostly in this movie
doing good work on a low-budget flick
with a decent story um weird [ __ ]
happens in it the ending is good but a
little bit underwhelming that was a guy
who was kind of realistic you know in a
way yeah that was kind of one of the
problems I was like I like I actually
liked this movie and I kept kind of I
was kind of invested it's not very long
it's only it's about an hour and a half
I think on the nose but basically so he
works at a night as a night clerk in
this hotel and he witnesses a murder
because what ends up happening is that
he has installed cameras in all of in
not all the hotel rooms but in some of
the hotel rooms and apparently it's not
for like perverted like jackoff material
but because he's interested in watching
people so that he can learn to mimic
them so he can like you know learn to
relate to other people better because
he's like you you see him like repeating
what they're saying and repeating their
gestures and facial expressions so he's
trying to like make himself better at
social interaction by watching people
when they don't know they're being
watched which like I said that's a very
questionable because it's very very
illegal for a hotel to have cameras in
there like that like in the bedrooms and
bathrooms and everything but he doesn't
seem to be you know he comes across as a
little creepy but not he's not really
aware that he's being creepy because he
doesn't think that that's a bad thing to
do he doesn't really have a concept that
he's like invading people's privacy
because for him it's not like a sexual
thing or a perverted thing it's just
he's just
observing people to see how they behave
so he can mimic it so he ends up seeing
a murder or you think that he well he
does witness a murder but you don't
really know exactly like who committed
it until later because they leave it a
little bit ambiguous but then it turns
out that because he had footage of the
murder happening because of the cameras
and the thing so he doesn't want to go
to the police about it so but police
think he did it becomes a suspect he
becomes a suspect because of his weird
behavior and like because of the [ __ ]
that he did like in the wake of the
murder he was he had a lot of stuff to
hide and they knew he was hiding
something they thought he was writing a
murder and there's really and he ends up
meeting a girl later on to who's who's
the girl from Blade Runner that look
yeah all right I'm calling her a girl
she's probably 35 yeah but you know to
me they all start looking pretty young
at my age there's anyway uh she shows up
and kind of like this weird kind of
romance kind of starts between the two
it's there you can't really can't really
say much more about the yeah cuz it'll
come it'll spoil the movie it's free
that was YouTube right
no no I mean I Netflix I mean yeah yeah
it's free on Netflix so I mean if you
pay for it if you have Napster that's
right do I guess so you know but it's a
decent one I will say that it's like I
liked the conceit of it I liked the
humor of it um I would have liked the
mystery to be a little bit more
mysterious I'll say that because I do
feel like even though they did leave
some stuff like kind of ambiguous like
oh we don't were not quite sure who did
this or quite sure what happened or
anything like that but then I feel like
it was a little predictable like I was
expecting more twists and turns than
actually occurred but like you said in a
way it was kind of more realistic it
wasn't kind of one of these crazy
thrillers where like all this like
implausible [ __ ] happens
telling of the movie the way it's shot
the visuals way looks it reminded me of
this it's in that same family of movies
that art of self-defense is in yeah well
you say that about every movie as like a
nerdy make it
well he has to make it has a
contemporary feel to it yeah you know it
feels like a 2020s movie yeah there's a
certain kind of tone that they have like
this like the way 80s movies have yeah
they're just something about the way
that it looks I don't know if it's
because it's not shot yeah I wish price
shot on film I don't know if really that
many people shoot on film today because
it felt kind of like HD video but
because every time they mean somebody
films like on actual film like the
lighthouse or something like that they
make like a big deal about it so I don't
I don't know if anyone is actually sure
they make it look like it was shot on
film I think but but it's just weird I
don't know it's filters I guess it's
digital but they've uses certain yeah
there's a lot of the interesting thing
is the production company behind this is
Saban films so the bomb whatever they're
all right yeah they started out with
Power Rangers that they've actually
started making like oh they did guns
akimbo as well that was pretty good
movie yeah which I actually really like
yeah there were some we had some
listener in the comment section pretty
good I liked it I actually like that yes
yes you know that's well that's the
thing it's like everybody's you know got
one from me for me movies are just
entertainment and I thought that was
pretty entertaining in a lot of times
like I I like movies and other people
don't like or you know I like things
that other people don't
it's like you know what I mean it it's
like I'm not gonna tell people you know
oh you don't like XYZ movie you're wrong
because that's dumb it's a subjective
opinion you know what I mean it's like
if you have a reason for not to actually
you don't even have to have a reason for
not liking something if you just will be
like man that for me whatever it's like
I'm not gonna [ __ ] argue with them
about with you better why but I do like
I used to know this I used to work with
this guy a long time ago it was like an
older guy and he was like super super
into movies and like me you know I I am
too so we we talked about that kind of
[ __ ] but he was kind of one of those
dudes where if you didn't like you know
this classic movie or if you didn't feel
the same way about it that he felt then
you were just wrong and he was just
going to like berate you and like argue
with you until you like submit
you know which to me is just a pointless
exercise because you know you're not
gonna get everybody to like everything
and some people even though I think some
people's opinions are stupid about
particular movies but you know there's
nothing you can do about it because
everybody just likes what they like and
um you know so this movie like I said
it's nothing groundbreaking it's nothing
it's kind of like a just a throwaway fun
kind of mystery thriller you know
mid-tier type of thank you not crazy
over the top it's not like some
convoluted like crazy Lifetime movie
that gives my although I like this I do
- so Melissa what about the pervy old
man [ __ ] perv ran out on a black
couple we saw that when in the [ __ ]
thing oh right right right yeah lifetime
well the thing about it it's like that
could have just been another like throw
away they know that was an okay mystery
thriller but because it was so like a
campy and over-the-top that it almost
like became super awesome yeah I don't
want to say what's that what's that
[ __ ] what's that actor's name Dennis
Quaid we do this way he's trying to be
as pervy as possible to around the
corner why he was always like creepy
place I was in the theater ran out we
saw that in the big screen it was
effective for me I was like going yeah
it's yeah I felt like we would to see
that and I think we went to see that at
night which we didn't usually and so
there was like quite a few people in
there and I feel like everyone was kind
of like having a good time yeah you just
can't take [ __ ] like that too seriously
like I said it's just like those
lifetime movies yeah that they have an
element of camp or you know just kind of
this over-the-top earnestness to them
that you can't help but like laugh at
but it also like makes them it reminds
meaning it reminded me of that one that
we saw back in the very late 80s early
90s
who's the guy that played the Batman out
of [ __ ] the old [ __ ] Batman [ __ ]
with the Tim Burton
yeah Michael Keaton Michael Keaton had
Michael Keaton and he was living oh
hello isn't letting a [ __ ]
just go and was that specific I think it
was specific heights
it was a bunch that came out like that
weeks in a week enough the house and
[ __ ] because remember like the 90s was
like a really big like killer thriller
yes you type of thing she had like
[ __ ] fatal attraction yeah white
females like like all those types of
movies I feel like ever like the late
80s to mid 90s really big time for that
yeah well because they were new or kind
of new yeah I mean it's a genre that's
been around forever that [ __ ] that was
kind of like Pacific Heights that's what
I'm pretty sure it was even though there
was more than one they rent like the
basement oh yeah yeah yeah and then he
starts bringing in cockroaches and
[ __ ] rats and then suing them and
making their life [ __ ] how they tried
yeah he was trying to take the house
from him one day yeah what was his
motivation was he just a nutcase or did
he have some other I think there was a
who's trying to tell you I think he was
trying to take the house it might have
been something like that because I feel
like you can't just have even if it's a
convoluted agenda you have to have an
agenda
you can't just be like well they're
crazy yeah sometimes crazy people do
crazy people things
yeah the desk wait flick reminded me of
that it yeah it did kind of now I
haven't seen Pacific Heights in a long
time so I don't know how over-the-top
that is I would have to tell you the guy
over the top did my head did the white
female was too but I really really
excited anymore in it
Pacific Heights wasn't it I don't think
so I thought it was like one of the big
[ __ ] it girls from the [ __ ] night
I think it a lot of Bend anymore because
I remember she was like super hot for
like a couple years maybe she did GI
Jane knows in her career um yeah well
[ __ ] was it I want to say no but I can't
really remember because I am bashing her
was somebody that sounds more correct
you remember hand that rocks the cradle
with Rebecca De Mornay I were related
because that was there was that was a
whole sub-genre of those seven movies
was like the crazy [ __ ] yeah kind of
thing like I said that was kind of
single white female fatal attraction
like grow the [ __ ] be crazy off shoot
yeah in a way in a way this one is kind
of like those but
not quite as intense yeah it needed a
little bit the way this movie ended
wasn't quite good enough I think it was
yeah it was a little bit
it was too realistic India I can it
should have should have gone over the
top because I thought that a mean you
know like I said I'm not gonna give
anything away if anybody wants to watch
it but there were a couple times when I
thought oh they're gonna do this twist
or they're gonna do that and then they
didn't do it and do it so I was just
kind of like okay so it's it's not like
a mystery thriller with a bunch of
twists it's just like a mystery thriller
and you think there's gonna be twists
and there's really kind of not yeah sure
to come out like oh that dude was never
autistic to begin with or the very end
you know that that's how I would really
enjoyed it turned out turned out he was
also a woman that's a shadow just a [ __ ]
I guess and a Bigfoot in an abyss why
don't they let me write also and also he
was a shark all along yeah
Melanie Griffith somebody said wasn't
Melanie Griffith I feel like it was more
me with Melanie Griffith Melanie
Griffith was in Pacific Heights more
than I think I feel like that's more
likely than to me more she yeah well she
just who was the audience understood it
was Melanie Griffith yeah that's okay
and she's talking about Pacific Heights
Yeah right now okay that's what I said
no I said that sounds more that sounds
more correct than anything we came up
with like I said without looking at
Wikipedia I'm not really sure
earlier the her best roles in Cherry mm
oh I don't know I did I thought it I
like cherry mm but I thought she was
really wooden in that a little bit but I
liked it I liked I liked her in the car
and the [ __ ] yeah you you want to
hear something like the Mad Max I hadn't
seen that movie since the early 90s
yeah or whenever it came out like I
started because I sure mm yeah 880 so
think it was 80 now well I mean I think
I saw it in 1990 or 91 on cable actually
my brother had a punk band back then
that was named after that movie but um
in fact she I perceived her as being so
wouldn't in that movie that when we
watched it again I could have sworn that
she was the robot like I thought I
thought that was the story it was the
really the person that was going to find
the part for the robot what I think I
think they went Snake Plissken with her
and she was basically trying to do a
female version of [ __ ] a [ __ ] Mel
Gibson yeah Amex or maybe like a female
version of [ __ ] Clint Eastwood mate
with her voice I guess good everything's
real monotone everything is real well
maybe it's just because she was too cute
to pull that off yes I think maybe what
is what it was they needed someone with
a little more like gravitas and we've
been older oh yeah
but that movie was supposed to be fun it
was just true that's true it was like on
really that was more inspired by [ __ ]
what was what's what's the name in that
one
something hunters in the Forbidden Zone
adventures in the space hunter adventure
in the Forbidden Zone
they had Molly Ringwald another guy was
like oh you were talking about that the
other day I said you haven't seen that
movie I don't gotta buy that movie I
mean I've seen so many movies it was
like a cross between Star Wars and Mad
Max yeah dude the spaceship lands on a
Mad Max planet he meets Molly Ringwald
and she's just a scavenger and they go
out looking for something in the in the
Forbidden Zone where Russia
I don't know cyborgs and [ __ ] I guess it
was like barbarians [ __ ]
sometimes I get that Jason's sin and the
[ __ ] metal storm that messy
destruction darren's in the [ __ ] that
had cyborgs in it and Mad Max 2 I kind
of remember that movie but like there
were so many there were so many that
they all care like bunched together like
in the late 80s like there were so many
post-apocalyptic yeah but in those two
at least they were wrecking [ __ ] they
built some vehicles and they wrecked
them yeah an erection you gotta wreck
[ __ ] yeah Oracle one says Melanie
Griffith Matthew Modine was the guy
thank you very much I was trying to
remember who that was and Michael Keaton
okay I feel like there was another movie
that came out around the same time
wasn't there what okay what about
Arlington Road wasn't that similar
with Tim Robbins I'm mostly remembered
like urban areas aramide just like
remember in aittle attract by degrees
and fatal attraction and Cape Fear and
yeah yeah yeah there was a nice round
[ __ ] we could do a whole show about like
all those like crazy thrillers they came
out of the 90s really Basic Instinct and
Cape Fear was one of De Niro's best
movies yeah you know I think he did a
[ __ ] great job in that movie being
that convict we have two ones that he's
turned into a crazy old man we're gonna
watch that again I think I think Netflix
or I just saw it like on Netflix or 2b
or something like that they just added
it like not too long ago Netflix just
added like a whole bunch of older movies
which I thought was kind of neat they
had us here they had [ __ ] Clash of the
Titans from 1981 I was so excited
although I probably have memorized that
movie at this point there's a lot of
stuff on there yes they put Silence of
the Lambs on there they put all kind of
[ __ ] on there all right so we've got
almost half an hour about this movie but
like I said it's you know it's a it's a
fine throwaway thriller kind of movie
with a little bit of a twist because it
has like you know a nasty as the main
character and all that entails I'm
talking about she loves space on her
okay yeah and Michael Ironside in it
also
he was might have seen that I want to
get a space hunter space hunter on
[ __ ] blu-ray that a metal storm that
one on blu-ray was like [ __ ] 30 or 40
bucks I'm not paying that much for that
piece of [ __ ] well yeah that movie was
not that great at cooling I just wanted
to see it because it's something you
kind of grow up with and you're like you
and I'm gonna see that [ __ ] again
yeah it's it was [ __ ] terrible but
you know that movie didn't even make
sense spade metal storm but I still it
had a lot of good [ __ ] wrecks in it
and this is a hell of a drug dollars
like even movies that I objectively that
are objectively terrible if I saw that
not always because sometimes I saw them
when they were you know when I was a kid
and I loved him and then I saw
when I was older I was like wow that
sucks yeah but sometimes there are some
movies like Greece - yeah that are
better which I saw when I was a kid and
loved it and then I was afraid to watch
it again I'm like oh I bet I'm not gonna
like it as not so good I did yeah yeah
it's terrible but I still love it yeah
there's what was another one there's
another one that I [ __ ] loved it when
I was a kid they did I [ __ ] I think I
paid [ __ ] twenty five or thirty
dollars for it on blu-ray transfers yeah
and then I got your answers and the
first five minutes of it is okay that's
what makes all the impression on you and
then that movie doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense then that's not even a movie it
was just a bunch of [ __ ] it's kind of a
collection the collection of C's strung
together
what the [ __ ] is this well we filmed
massaged it into it didn't make any
[ __ ] sense and I'm not sure it made
sense back in the 80s I mean but I
thought it made sense I you know back
then I thought it made sense were you in
fact that's what I remember I mean I was
high off and on but chances are we
probably only watched the first 10 15
minutes of it and then talked through
the rest of it I think that's kinda what
happens a lot because it's like yeah you
run it a movie with your buddies instead
of them sometimes you'd be watching be
like yeah this is awesome but then you'd
like start doing us talking then you
look back at it some happens and then
you yeah I got cool yes but you miss all
the like boring [ __ ] yeah but what's
funny is that they made like seven of
those did they yeah seven yeah the guys
are involved in it [ __ ] started to uh
like well yeah run with it to kind of
like kind of like phantasm you know it
was privately owned and they just kept
raising money making you know
well the first one only costs like two
dollars and fifty cents so might as well
makes you wonder did he get better or
did he get worse I would bet a
substantial amount of money that it's
that second thing yeah that they got
worse yeah I mean they almost always get
how could that get worse though don't
ask that question there's always a way
you always think that like a movie that
you see it's like there's no way the
soup eyes will be worse and then
somebody out there somewhere it's like
hey hold my beer I'm gonna make like
we're talking about transfers transfers
transfers transfers was a movie that IRA
I thought it was the way we remembered
it was like Blade Runner well you were
really talking it up and I don't I
didn't dare that I had ever seen it so
you paid like 20 something dollars yeah
yeah movie that I'm watching it I'm like
was good after it was over JT was like
so did you like that movie or what no we
remembered it like Blade Runner that's
how we considered it back is it really
not like and what it was it was well
they had some guys that were kind of
like blade runners they were like
private dicks from the [ __ ] that's
crazy [ __ ] huh they're like privatized
they were like privatized for there'd
being a public dick I guess nobody wants
to see that [ __ ] they were like
privatized from the future okay and look
yeah and they were looking for people in
the past and they traveled into the past
not by going through a time vortex but
by taking this weird drug that would
make their consciousness shift to their
ancestors and they would wake up and one
of their ancestors one of their
ancestors bodies and then go look for uh
so they did through their DNA somehow
that does not sound like a good time and
then they would so you could just be a
random dude in the here and now all of a
sudden you just yeah you know one of my
[ __ ] descendants has now possessed me
basically and then they start address
some like they addressed in the future
when they did in the future they dressed
kind of like something out of the
forties the hats and the [ __ ] trench
coats and [ __ ] ray guns and smoking a
lot and they were going out looking for
criminals that were hiding in the past
that's what it was yeah and they were
doing it the same way they were escaping
into their ancestors by you
in this [ __ ] injection it's a good
idea that was a good idea I'm going back
in the past to try to get him it's like
arrest him somehow yeah kill him no it
was like that's opening up a whole new
can of worms is like well you can't like
how do you bodily put a person in jail
like because of something that their
future yeah
person did and their consciousness is in
the body but that's not their body so
it's like that's not what in the future
these such these transfers okay these
guys that were going into the past to
hunt down these escaped criminals they
gave two shits about whether whose body
you're in there's like what a good yeah
yeah no they would you know they would
kill you
disintegrate yeah you probably did
something no you didn't care like in the
future things were real [ __ ] I guess
you could say this futuristic and real
brutal like the human life didn't really
have a whole lot of value and they
didn't and things weren't really run by
law or justice it was as you would know
it it was kind of like kind of like
Judge Dredd you know looking where they
were judge jury and executioner type
guys but what the movie ended up being
was dudes in their [ __ ] 60s 60s
running around trying to [ __ ] haven't
having love scenes with girls in their
20s that's what the [ __ ] little like
the most
granddad yes so nasty
oh we just they were the ones fat they
were the ones finance in the movie so it
was up you know well yeah they paid to
make out with me let's call it what it
is the way it was well you still is that
way they just hide it I wanted to say we
got a message from somebody named Martin
Fullwood that said that said hey guys
I'm new to your channel so hey how you
doing welcome yep it's on my trances
even though that was always started out
talking about but yeah you know since
you're new to the show that's kind of
what always happens cuz we never really
script any of this [ __ ] so it's like you
never know what we're gonna talk about
because we don't know what we're going
to talk about half the time sometimes we
see a jag death that's what his name was
and he says there's six of them and the
best one is the first one god that
seemed like a horrible because that
first one was terrible
yeah no bad they're good I wonder if
there's if there's a RiffTrax I would
imagine because um with tracks they I
mean they must never sleep or anything
because they have a riff tracks for like
yeah and everything holy crap
good movies bad movies in different
movies they've done a rip drugs for yeah
jag debt that's right they had this
[ __ ] corny corny [ __ ] Private Eye
outfits they were always wearing [ __ ]
with the big white eyes and the [ __ ]
zoot suits hats and yeah it was almost
kind of like a damn zoot suit big show
if they were trying to do the neo-noir
yeah neo-noir was kind of like a zoot
suit that they were wearing and [ __ ]
Blade Runner cars in shape they show
them from the future
remember that lousy suit riot yeah by
the cherry poppin daddies yes I can't
imagine there the other that the other
five were [ __ ] worse than one one was
like a you know hearing here don't ever
say that it's like how can a movie be
worse than that it can always always be
worse they didn't know how to write a
story there is no bottom of your Errol
it's just the barrel just keeps going
down forever he's laughing yeah yeah
big-ass [ __ ] trench coats your
[ __ ] tan trench because I think the
head shoulder pads in them dudes had
like a foot daily yeah my goes like a
[ __ ] Zoot Suit kind of look like kind
of look like gaff from Blade Runner but
but more ridiculous and they showed him
in the future
they had diners and [ __ ] like nineteen
fifties diners and I remember that's the
only thing the only scene was women in
the future that kind of stuck with the
diner saying the diner well and we just
saw it like obably six months ago and
that's literally the only dinner yeah
and the first one opens up with that
diner scene and for some reason that
scene fools you into thinking that you
like this movie
hypnotizes yeah yeah there's the rest of
the movie there's no there's nothing
there the rest of the movie so kind of
like subliminal message yeah never
happens again it's like you could just
have like [ __ ] 30 minutes of her you
know hour-and-a-half like white noise
every be a this is the best right so uh
alright let's wrap this show up we'll
probably do another live stream again
tomorrow either a side tracks or if we
find another new movie that we want to
watch might watch that tonight and
review it as well but like I said if you
have Netflix and you don't have anything
pressing to do and you have an hour half
kill and would like to see a thriller
mystery that's fairly entertaining then
you could certainly do worse than the
night clerk and like got some good
acting in it I always like to see John
Leguizamo he's a cool guy and uh you
know in a darkness yeah [ __ ] job
getting [ __ ] beat up by [ __ ] life
no Steven Seagal that's right or that
yeah he's an amazing man poor John
Leguizamo although I have to say what I
say is long I have to say that made me
love John Leguizamo even more when he
actually laughed at Steven Seagal yeah
face like for saying that because in
flashes that's why would it what I would
have done to you because that is
everything or --ml person knows that
that's a ridiculous thing to say to
somebody else yeah and and the fact that
Steven Seagal would actually beat up
John Leguizamo who is considerably
smaller than him yeah um you know what I
mean yeah like it's almost like five
five yeah yeah and doesn't work out or
anything it would have been way funnier
though I mean if that story had ended
with John Leguizamo just like Kate's ass
kicking him in the taint
yeah contrary contrary to [ __ ] Steven
Seagal's [ __ ] beliefs Steven Seagal
is not a badass no no you don't say he's
not a badass I can't believe that he's
tall but there's not much even
even when he was when he was in his
prime he was tall he was thin you look
at him yeah he's not conditioned he
doesn't have any arms he doesn't well
that's what I mean he has size on him
like in the sense that he towers over
most yeah and he has long arms and he
probably weighed close to 200 pounds but
it was just guts and bone you know I
mean and later on spleens and livers
waste the gall is now I mean he's got
stunt doubles to walk up and down the
stairs for him now that's not a joke I'm
never gonna let him live that down you
see he's got stunt doubles that just
walk out in the balcony and look yep yep
you go wait hold on that wasn't ham and
you back it up looking as that is not
[ __ ] and they'll only he'll only have
himself shot from like the bottom lip up
no the next thing you know you seen from
another angle and it's not him he
doesn't want you to know that that dudes
this big around as a [ __ ] truck tire
but yeah experience we never get well we
never get tired of making fun of him
because he just takes himself seriously
and people that take themselves too
seriously and actually think they're
badasses they're like way more fun to
make fun of he's an amazing he's an
amazing man he he talked his way into
movies he says he weighs a lot more than
200 pounds well yeah he does now back in
the old days back in the old days he'd
cry weigh 200 just because he was so
he's oh yeah he probably maybe he didn't
weigh 200 he might have weighed 180 190
a probably 200 but he if you look at his
arms is just enough there's no
conditioning no muscle there's no mass
on him most of time when they shot him
they shot him in long sleeves I shot him
in some kind of uniform to make him look
a little more when he was [ __ ] the
youngins when he was at his best shape
and he was doing Aikido he's got that
big old [ __ ] samurai dress uh-huh I'm
gonna call the Sam Rogers gee it's got
that big old guy on and he looks mad
and kind of like very robust but it's
that gay it's all tall and skinny he's
tall and skinny he was tall skinny in
his I wouldn't know her thick because
the top of it they like OHS look tight
yes maybe picture Steven Seagal in
janko's man I seen geneco's I think
thanks for that I remember the time and
girls down to [ __ ] mall and janko's
it's [ __ ] tongue rings and [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] tongue rings and janko's and
[ __ ] yeah so he said he was in a vampire
movie not too long ago I can't remember
the name of that movie but uh I'm
terrible he did it on [ __ ] case cinema I
haven't sat through the whole thing but
[ __ ] case enema did it yeah I feel like
everybody else does everything in the
movie he's just there yeah yeah he
doesn't do anything everyone
orbits around him Lee is a gigantic and
les system [ __ ] okay now it's time to
kill vampires just watch me so okay you
do it and what's funny is that I got a
bad knee in anesthesia in a modern
Steven Seagal movie he does his little
work as possible they say that he's
never really on set um they'll shoot a
few hours of him and then they'll kind
of weave that into a movie that they
shot yeah it's not even his voice half
the time it's and it's not even it's
somebody dubbing him over which explains
to all the different accents yeah no not
really
somebody else dub dub him over and it's
not even a good Seagal impersonation I
can do Segal better than I'm actually
not entirely sure what his real voice or
accent sounds like he he becomes
whatever race he's talking to yeah okay
if you're black chameleon if you're
black he becomes black
if if you're southern he becomes
something if you're Italian
he becomes a ten
if you're talking about martial arts he
becomes Japanese be the Asian experience
get inside again he's got about 9
million kids bunch of different wives
really has to piss in and he talked his
way into [ __ ] meeting Vladimir Putin
Vladimir Putin was definitely tripped
out by him just yeah he moves to Russia
to escape some lawsuit as far as I far
as I know Leakey's own [ __ ] sexual
assault charges he's running from she
goes to Russia and he just pestered the
Putin administrators himself like all
right yeah and then a Putin was amused
but but he they figured out quickly that
he was he's a hack yeah he's a hack
now somebody else he did live in Japan
yeah uh he did for a little while when
he was younger he was young when he was
yeah he was fairly young real young yeah
and twenties maybe
he doesn't speak Japanese he wasn't
there very long they see claim to have
studied under this great Aikido master
that's not true yeah he did learn a
little he did learn some Aikido why he
was there but it didn't have anything to
do with that
Grand Master he wasn't a very important
student yeah but he could do a Kido he
was a real Aikido practitioner the
problem is is uh when you practice real
Aikido Aikido is not a real martial art
that's the problem
yeah it doesn't work well yeah yeah if
you tried to use Aikido on a mixed
martial artist you would get you ass
whipped
yeah but very very quickly yeah I've
sent before another shows I know we have
some people that are new to the show my
step-brother Billy was a [ __ ] when it
back in high school is like a [ __ ]
second or third degree Taekwondo black
belt
I watched him kick [ __ ] three and
four dude's asses simultaneously alright
these are big dudes after school and
[ __ ] he could he could he was he but he
was six foot
and he could just beat your ass I
watched him do it and then I realized
when I saw him beat those dudes asses he
wasn't really using Taekwondo he just
used punches yeah you didn't using the
flying kicks or the [ __ ] and it seems
like too much for me just yeah and you
tell you tell you you know he told me I
said he says yeah but you know all that
stuff's for show and for points and for
competitions the kids they're just
judging you and and but he just whipped
your ass just with [ __ ] fists and he
would kick you he could kick you in the
face while I was standing right in front
of you
yeah but the kicks usually took too long
so it's just because like I said your
arm is right there yeah very near to the
other year since face your legs way down
but I did see him kick a dude in the
face because he punched one do this in
front of him and then kicked a dude
behind him in the face but it didn't
look like martial arts it just look like
a dude whipping people look like to me
well yeah things are the life and things
they put yeah it's like they have to do
a different rosin so most of the time in
real life it doesn't look as cool now if
you took Billy and put him and put him
in a ring with him with a modern mixed
martial artists ability got his ass
kicked yeah because those fights end up
on the ground the only reason why Billy
was able to do what he was doing is
because he was fighting basically
untrained fighters they were just
untrained thugs or badasses
you know I mean but they wouldn't really
have any formalized training and he was
mostly knocking him out with single
blows yeah so he was sweet spot in him
in a Jaa's and just one blow and it
would knock them out and then you move
on to the next one and you know the guys
would take a long time to recover and
usually just knocked the will right out
and they did want to fight after being
knocked out yeah so but he was good at
that but anyway that was a big side
track when you defend yourself and your
attacker yes that's right
we don't want anyone and lling yorda
tackers attack away from you into some
other helpless mother it's just [ __ ]
yeah so he says we should do a watch
party with private
somebody's like we should probably get
into doing that one of these days
although I kind of worry you cuz we say
funny [ __ ] we're watching movies all the
time but I always kind of worry that
we're just gonna sit there and not say
hey buddy are not as funny we are like I
have to keep it packed [ __ ] with
constant [ __ ] comments and [ __ ] and
I'd be drinking and it would get way out
of hand and well no that's good though
but you'd have to be careful about which
movies that you picked would you like I
said it would have to be something like
Mystery Science Theater where it was so
ridiculous that you'd always have
somebody to comment on yeah you have to
pick something that was like kind of
great like not boring or anything
because otherwise she'd be sitting there
going yeah what is this gonna be over
all right so like I said we will
probably do another live stream tomorrow
either at 2:00 or 3:00 in the afternoon
Eastern Time it'll be either be another
movie review or might be another side
tracks which I guess this kind of was -
because we always go off on various
things the love which that was a good
movie I don't know why you mentioned it
offhand but I just saw it come up in the
thing and I was like that was actually a
good movie it was on know shudder it's
kind of a throwback looks like a giallo
movie but like with magic and and stuff
it was cool all right so we will talk to
you guys again tomorrow and uh as always
thank you for dropping by